you know what Trump's Twitter account
should be suspended his Twitter account
should be suspended I think there is
plenty of now evidence to suggest that
he is irresponsible with his words in a
way that could result in harm to other
people and so the privilege of using
those words in that way should probably
be taken from him further proof that
Kamala would make a bad president her
instinct when faced with something bad
it and really she's not gonna help
herself by D tweeting Trump if anything
that might help him he just quickly
launched his own message board and the
media would cover that even more
breathlessly because without trumps
asides they'd have to start covering
real news which actually takes real work
and besides we'd all resent miss harris
for taking away one of the most striking
phenomenons in political history a
leader who communicates directly to the
people cutting out the middleman known
as us the media obnoxious or not it's
the most transparent advancement in
politics the opposite of the
choreographed interview between
politicians and hacks that allowed both
phonies to prosper no wonder she hates
it she's terrible at being authentic
she's as real as spandex as credible as
a gas station chili dog I've never seen
a candidate so uncomfortable in her own
pantsuit well maybe the only person who
laughs more at their own jokes is the
Joker it's really difficult to drink out
of a paper straw when you had if you're
just like if you don't gulp it down
immediately it starts to bend and then
you know the little thing catches it and
then you know but so we got a kind of
perfect
which tweak what we are the about saying
that it is a modern day lynching that
sorry so there's a weird reflex among
lives these days not to engage in
dialogue but simply suppress it instead
of debating each other
dump the interesting voices instead of
listening to the other side called
despicable or deplorable instead of
accepting an election resist it and call
it illegitimate what do all these
tactics have in common they only work if
you know you're a loser you know Dana
you remember I had high hopes for Kamala
way back when she and she was the first
to announce yes said the Rubio model yes
I thought that she had it but she said
that big an out and she had the big
crowd and even President Trump remember
at the time I think he tweeted that she
had a big crowd and then he was
impressed with her yeah I think that
right now she's doing everything that
she can to punch through in this new
cycle because when you start talking
about impeachment it there's basically
no room for anything else so she has to
figure out a way to do that the other
thing that she tried to do today was to
make some news basically saying she's
got some staff changes on her campaign
which is an acknowledgement that things
are not going that well she has not
announced her campaign finance numbers
for this last quarter I bet that they're
nothing good no she has I think she's
raised over ten eleven million dollars
below she's a phenomenal woman a great a
wonderful lawyer if you ever need a
lawyer great but what she was saying was
that words matter and I do believe the
word to the president United States
matters but the family he's spent so I
think we need to timeout some time
especially over the weekend when I'm
watching football and the president is
tweeting 80 times and it's all like
talking loud and saying nothing she was
she was Greg I know better she was
making the point that his words not
especially when the president sometime
retweet people who are saying things
that may not you know yeah well I
correct myself she had I just didn't see
it was eleven point six million dollars
dude and it's too late to correct it's
wrong the record
and we'll be happy we will have a
meeting after the show to discuss
disciplinary procedures but here's the
thing okay
Donna's point Jedidiah it's hard for
leftist not Donna to lecture us on words
when they've been they've said a lot of
horrible things about conservatives
going back to Reagan going back however
long and so now we got a guy that kind
of fights back and now suddenly whoa and
even on Twitter I mean you had so many
politicians on the left that wanted to
destroy the Covington kids and second
one that and set out to destroy Brett
Kavanaugh they decided he was guilty
tried to ruin his whole career so even
if you don't like Trump's Twitter feed
and I get it sometimes I look at it and
I'm like oh man just Melania take that
away I mean I go through that that range
of a moment like that with your Twitter
but yeah I know that it's not it's not
just on the Left attack on the righty so
ya know nobody ahead all the time but
nobody cared until Trump the problem is
you would have to ban so many people
that you would have to ban the whole
platform yes well you don't know right
there's people on the way do you cross
the line when you retweet stuff that
involves civil war I mean Adam Kinzinger
I did I pronounced it right you did you
know Greg is gonna take me back to
grammar school school that he's never
been to okay it's just that I'm so close
to Jesse I can't share a lot of the
rulers would ban the books yes people
whose ideas threaten their power and
then the Catholic Church would issue
Brooke bans on some of the Copernicus
not interested in things like that
because it verdict is novels yes their
ideology and as you remember in 1440
when the printing press was invented by
Steve Guttenberg yes throughout Europe
but what this says is Greg throughout
history when the elites feel that their
power is threatened by new ideas and new
information their instinct is to destroy
it is not to persuade it is not to
debate this is destroyed and then that
is what Kamala Harris is doing that what
all people on the Left have been do
recently look at Rudy Guiliani they
tried to keep him off air look what they
did with Trump's Twitter account look
what they did with Ben Shapiro who is
about 5 foot 3 least threatening guy in
the world he can't speak on a college
campus right now because he's too
threatening this just shows how weak the
left is and they can't persuade with
ideas and now they're trying to take
away your vote and that's the most
critical good point though it's true
it's like if they can't beat you on the
turf they just remove the turf right you
know there's an old saying that politics
is a context people need to get tough
right here burial protecting all of our
supporters from these harsh mean words
from this monster states and words
matter I bet you LBJ was 10 times worse
but there wasn't Twitter right
no he used a tape recorder yeah I will
go back to the tape recorder for Trump
yes